Here is an interesting needle-out-of-work tuck
stitch that's easy to do
and creates a light, open fabric.
This technique is often called tuck lace.
Sometimes tuck can get
a bit heavy and dense.
Keeping needles out of work can help
to create a more lightweight fabric.
All three of these images
are the same swatch.
Right side, wrong side, wrong
side, the choice is yours.
I've cast on over every other
needle and knit two rows.
Now, remember, tuck needs weight,
so not only will I weight my cast on edge,
I'll move claw weights up the side
of my knitting as it grows.
Following my pattern, I'm manually pulling
every-other-needle in work
to hold position.
Set the carriage to hold
and tuck for 4 rows.
Then I'll cancel hold
and knit one closing row.
For the next sequence,
I'll keep those same needles
in out of work position,
but this time I'll pull the opposite
working needles into hold.
Make sure my carriage is set to hold,
those needles are all the way out
into hold position,
knit four rows and knit a closing row.
Now, alternating the tuck stitches
gives the smocking effect that you see.
Notice that I'm not
tucking the edge needles.
This will give me a good
solid edge for seaming.
And you can see the little extra
weight on those edges really helps.
I hope you'll give this
stitch pattern a try.
It's a pretty one, not hard to do,
and will open up your eyes to some
possibilities of tuck lace.